[Music]
this little pig is looking good
hey baby hey
any help
no
do you want to do my next
why
well it just seems like a thing mothers
and daughters might do
what's wrong with you
nothing
never mind
jorge what you up to good morning
everybody
want to go out and get some ice cream
i'm watching this well when it's over
not really
okay
want to play monopoly i'll let you be
the thimble
we'll poo to you
what about the little dog
and there are two ends all right
you want to go bowl a few frames don't
you see me watching the wheel
you can just say no
no
have you talked to john tonight yeah and
he and children were watching tv without
anybody yakking at him
i'm going home
thanks for stopping by
i fell
i fell
[Music]
what do you want i baked you a pie
why
well i was thinking we haven't had the
best history as neighbors that's cause
we don't like each other
right so i thought we could sit down
over a slice of rhubarb pie and you know
forgive and forget
i haven't done anything that needs
forgiven
okay well
that sounds like something we could sit
down and talk about over the pie mom i'm
bleeding again
you know what mary i appreciate it but
this isn't a great time bobby stabbed
billy in the leg with a fork good lord
is he okay it was a plastic fork but it
broke the skin pretty good oh okay i
understand how about i take that pie and
give you a rain check
um sure i think there's mustard in the
fork gotta go
you can keep the pan
pretty much what it looks like
would you like some company
sure i guess
of course if you'd rather watch tv i
could leave you alone no no no it should
rerun
but even if it weren't
what's wrong nothing keep going
mary
george i just missed my little boy so
much and he's never gonna come back
because he doesn't need his mama baby of
course you'll come back no you should
have seen how happy he was
all right well you still got georgie and
missy
oh dear oh yeah
oh dear
[Applause]
no kid it's chilly out
[Music]
i changed my mind i don't want to leave
here ever
you never have to
[Music]
let my spirit